here's the next attitude disease
over caution
some people never will have much they're
too cautious
now you can also be too Reckless but you
can also be too cautious
this is called the timid approach to
life
and my caution was always the risk risk
used to drive me right up the wall
I used to say what if this happens
it's called the language of the poor
what if this happens and on top of that
if this was to happen look at the fix
I'd be in I better not try
I could always Ace myself out
then I'll tell you what changed my whole
life when I finally discovered
it's all risky
the minute you were born it got risky
if you think trying is risky wait till
they hand you the bill for not trying
if you think investing is risky wait
till you get the tab for not investing
see it's all risky getting married is
risky having children is risky going
into business is risky investing your
money is risky it's all risky
I'll tell you how risky life is you're
not going to get out alive
that's risky
the Englishman says well if that's the
way it's going to work out let's give it
a go right that's what it's for give it
a go
somebody says yeah but I'm looking for
Safety and Security fine then huddle in
a corner
we'll cover you with a sheet bring you
three meals a day
and we'll protect you feed you look
after you care for you we won't let
anything happen to you and you'll
probably live to be 100.
the guy said well yeah I'd live to be
one hunt but what a way to live right
what a way to live safe and secure don't
ask for security ask for adventure
better to live 30 years full of
Adventure than 100 years safe in the
corners
and see it's not important how long you
live what's important is how you live
pessimism the deadly disease of always
looking on the bad side the problem side
the difficult side checking all the
reasons why it can't be done
the poor pessimist leads an ugly life
he doesn't try to figure out what's
right he tries to figure out what's
wrong
he doesn't look for virtue he looks for
faults and when he finds him he's
delighted how
ugly
this is the poor guy looks through the
window doesn't see the sunset he sees
the specks on the wind and this is the
poor guy right who rushes up takes such
leave of his senses this guy rushes up
and he says I've got five good reasons
why it won't work
he's so dumb he doesn't know all he
needs one he's got five to the pessimist
the glasses always have
empty to the Optimus the glasses have
why would the same measure affect people
two different ways answer it all depends
on how you look at it
our lives are mostly affected by the way
we think things are
not the way they are
the way we think they are affects us
most I hear a knock on my door one day
and I go to the door and there's a
little girl about this tall selling Girl
Scout cookies
and she gave me the big pitch on Girl
Scout cookies finest organization in the
world
got these cookies only two dollars
support the Girl Scouts
no problem I wanted to and with a big
smile she politely asked me to buy
I did want to buy
big problem
I didn't have two dollars in my pocket
so I thought I can't tell her that
so I thought well next best I lied to
her
and I said look I've already bought lots
of Girl Scout cookies I've still got
plenty in the house that we haven't
eaten yet
she said well that's wonderful thank you
very much and she leaves
when she leaves I say to myself
I don't want to live like this
anymore
I mean how how low can you get lying to
a Girl Scout I mean that's
that's as low as it gets
so I promised myself that day it would
never happen again the first essence of
life
and that is self-preservation
to produce enough to take care of
yourself
the instructions given right to the
to the couple that left the Garden of
Eden one was to multiply it's a lonely
place with only two people
but here were the next instructions to
be fruitful
how fruitful how productive should one
be
and here's number one to produce enough
to survive
to produce enough to take care of
yourself
and self-care is important
if you're flying on an airplane the
flight attendant says if for some reason
we run out of oxygen
these oxygen masks will fall from the
ceiling and
if you have
children with you quickly take care of
them
then take care of yourself
no
no no no no
they say what put your mask on first
put your mask on first see to your
survival
first then you'll be more capable of
taking care of the survival of your
children
isn't that interesting
my father had an interesting saying he
said son right after me you come first
you got to be careful see it doesn't
matter who hands you the bad stuff
it doesn't matter where you get the bad
stuff it'll still do its damage on your
bank account
wherever you get it
Mr shelf gave me one of the greatest
phrases when I first met him when he
said Jim every day stand guard at the
door of your mind
how important
stand guard at the door of your mind
and you decide what goes into your
mental Factory don't let anybody just
dump anything they want to in your
mental Factory because you've got to
live with the results
the last disease but this one is deadly
engage in this one indulge in it even
slightly and you might as well forget
the future because it's going to forget
you
complaining
[Music]
crying whining griping a Bible word
called murmuring see that'll Ace your
future spend five minutes complaining
and you have wasted five
and you may have begun what's known as
economic cancer of the bone
just be on the lookout of the things
that can destroy all the good you start
the war is on
and this evening tomorrow mentally
personally socially economically you got
to make sure you're winning the war and
this is part of it